ce devait être le crime parfait la
victime alexandre litvinenko un
dissident russe ancien agent secret et
critique implacable de vladimir poutine
les assassins présumés dimitri cov
thoune et andreï lougovoï deux anciens
agents secrets russes devenu détective
privé en russie et en europe le 1er
novembre 2006 il passe à l'action au
millennium hôtel à londres une caméra de
surveillance enregistre 24 heures sur 24
tout ce qui se passe à la réception ces
enregistrements des présumés meurtriers
ont été récemment rendus publics
lougovoï ecofuel apparaît sur la vidéo
du 1er novembre vers 15h20 les deux
hommes entrent au bar du lobby de
l'hôtel ils commandent trois tasses de
thé et quelques gin tonic
selon la preuve ils se servent d'eux
tasse de thé avant de verser dans la
théière une petite quantité de polonium
210 une substance extrêmement
radioactive
à 15h33 une caméra de surveillance
montre andreï lougovoï qui se rend aux
toilettes ça ma gauche et dissimulés
dans la poche de son manteau
à 15h48 co-pdg va aussi aux toilettes
l'un d'eux ou les deux laissent des
traces de radioactivité sur la porte
en entrant dans les toilettes puis
encore au moment de se laver les mains
et d'utiliser le séchoir
au même moment alexandre litvinenko est
en route pour l'hôtel à 15h40 cap
on le voit sur cette image d'une caméra
de surveillance il se dirige vers
l'hôtel
il arrive à 16 heures pile comme en
témoigne cette autre image de la caméra
de surveillance à la réception
litvinenko zira plus tard à la police
qui n'avait vu que deux ou trois petites
gorgées de thé qu'il trouve
particulièrement amer des semaines plus
tard les policiers détecte une très
forte radioactivité dans la théière tout
particulièrement dans le bec verseur
même si c'est un poison mortel le
polonium agi lentement litvinenko ne
ressens rien sur le chemin du retour un
peu après minuit il est pris de
violentes nausées
il est hospitalisé et meurt au bout
d'une longue agonie de 23 jours avant de
mourir il identifie lougovoï est cof
thoune ainsi que d'autres personnes
comme c'est possible empoisonneurs mais
dans sa déposition à la police
il précise que le véritable coupable se
trouve en russie
je connais bien le système et je sais
que l'ordre de tuer un citoyen dans son
pays en particulier en grande-bretagne
ne peut venir que d'une seule personne
en russie pour y vont nous dire qui est
cette personne
c'est le président de la fédération de
russie vladimir poutine
on ignore les accusations de litvinenko
contre poutine ont été rendues publiques
le jour de sa mort le leader russe a
immédiatement nier allant même jusqu'à
laisser entendre que rien ne prouve que
lydie namco a été assassiné you ce
nombre étant ce qu'il courait chez ni
aux caselles ionatos le meurtre
d'alexandre litvinenko a été au coeur
d'une enquête publique de la cour royale
de justice à londres
le juge robert wayne a épluché les
milliers de pages de la preuve et
entendu des centaines de témoins afin
d'éclaircir ce mystère et de répondre à
cette question centrale
pourquoi vladimir poutine ou son
entourage
voulait-il cibler un dissident si tu es
si bas dans la hiérarchie
pourquoi alexandre litvinenko sur cette
photo il à peu près 18 ans marina
litvinenko est la veuve d'alexandre elle
l'appelait sa chatte et si les
grands-parents de sacha son grand-père
sa grand mère litvinenko est à peine
adolescent quand il s'engage dans le kgb
quand marine à le rencontrer l'épousé en
ils sont dans la jeune trentaine elle
est étonnée quand elle apprend qu'il
travaille pour les services secrets
russes maintenant appelée fsb à la sauce
h
quand j'ai connu ce achat il n'avait
absolument pas l'air de l'officier de
service secret pas du tout ils étaient
très minces
il avait l'air très jeune il était aussi
très timide shay c'est sa personnalité
qui a pris le dessus dans mon esprit
plus que son métier
j'étais très fier de lui
journaliste au guardian luke harding a
couvert l'anc est sûre litvinenko
il a vécu plusieurs années en russie est
l'auteur du livre mafia state alexandre
litvinenko mené une carrière d'officier
pour les renseignements russes dans les
années 90 il a commencé à travailler
pour le fsb sa spécialité était le crime
organisé la mafia russe il a travaillé
très fort sur ce dossier puis au milieu
des années 90 un événement majeur est
survenu on a tenté d'assassiner boris
berezovski qui joue un rôle central
auprès de boris eltsine un jean
d'éminence grise qui tirait les ficelles
en coulisses litvinenko a été chargé de
trouver qui était derrière la tentative
d'assassinât des lui vers le haut ce
qu'ils sont devenus m
c'est une bande qui a explosé tout près
de la voiture du berezovski su en son
chauffeur et un garde du corps durant l'
enquête un lien de confiance s'était
établi en clic vinko et berezovski qu'il
considérait comme son garde du corps
l'homme d'affaires avait plusieurs
ennemis surtout dans le fsb autrefois
kgb les patrons de litvinenko lui ont
demandé de les aider à tuer père et au
ski
il est venu me voir et m'a demandé tu
connais perez offs qui j'ai répondu que
oui il attire tu dois le tuer
je n'ai pas répondu et je lui montrais
les murs des micros étaient cachés dans
plusieurs bureaux
alors il s'est penché et m'a dit tout
bas
tu dois le tuer c'est à toi de le faire
aussi bonne chose litvinenko a refusé et
a tout révélé à berezovsky et à sa femme
marina je n'arrivais pas y croire la
première fois qu'il me l'a dit ça m'a
semblé si absurde au qui pouvait bien
vouloir tuer berezovsky et quels étaient
les motifs
berezovski non plus n'arrivais pas à y
croire en juillet 1998
berezovski convainc le président lte
chine de faire le ménage dans le fsb est
de placer à sa tête haute c'est ami
vladimir poutine il organise une
rencontre entre poutine et
jean cau pour aborder le problème de la
corruption dans le fsb
j'ai remis mon rapport mais il a refusé
de le prendre
il a juste regarder les tableaux puis a
demandé mon numéro à la maison j'ai
demandé pourquoi il m'a dit je vais vous
appelez plus tard un ami du fsb s'est
moqué de moi tu as vraiment choisi le
bon gars poutine
ils ne t'ont pas pris au sérieux et ils
ont pris ton numéro de téléphone je lui
ai dit comment tu le sais il a répondu
poutine nous a donné l'ordre de tout
mettre sous écoute alex goldfarb un ami
de longue date d'alexandre litvinenko a
co écrit avec sa veuve
le livre meurtre d'un dissident pro
poutine venait tout juste d'être nommé à
la tête d'une énorme agence il avait
maintenant sous ses ordres bien des gens
beaucoup plus haut gradé qui ne l'avait
jamais son succès en tant que nouveau
directeur ne lui viendrait pas de ses
appuis politiques et de la confiance de
généraux du kgb il a dû lutter pour
mériter leur soutien et leur accord
alors quand litvinenko cet officier
marginal lui est arrivé avec des
allégations de corruption
on comprend lien avec le recul que
poutine ne l'a pas porter dans son coeur
litvinenko courant alors public ces
allégations de corruption à moscou lors
d'une extraordinaire conférence de
presse télévisée
plusieurs de ses collègues dont certains
sont masquées qu'on préserver leur
anonymat soutiennent avec lui que des
policiers hauts-gradés assassine
littéralement des ennemis politiques
chine n'aime pas les gens qui décident
de parler publiquement des opérations
secrètes ou même d'un tri yann interne
je crois que ça l'a rendu furieux quand
il a vu que ça se produise est donc
pouvoir s'est mis à attaquer directement
litvinenko qui s'est retrouvé dans une
situation très difficile
litvinenko est rapidement arrêté et
accusé de multiples crimes reposant sur
de fausses accusations
pour lui ce simulacre de justice ne
pouvait venir que de poutine
évitez les règles du kgb sont claires on
ne parle pas publiquement des opérations
de l'organisation
sinon brise les règles et ça fait de
nous un traître et un traître qui mérite
d'être puni
litvinenko n'est pas condamné mais lui
et boris berezovski jusque ils ne sont
plus en sécurité en russie
ils planifient leur évasion litvinenko
convainc sa femme d'amener leur fils en
vacances en espagne
il quitte le pays et annonce à marina
ses plans de faire défection à l'ouest
et c'est dommage il m'a dit on pourrait
bien ne pas rentrer en russie
je lui ai dit pas question où veux tu
qu'on aille qu'est ce qu'on va faire
il m'a répondu marina c'est certain
qu'ils vont m'arrêter
ils vont sûrement vous faire du tort à
toi et un autre fils et personne ne va
nous sauver nous défendre
qu'est-ce que tu choisis et j'ai dit
c'est sûr que je vais sauver ma famille
le royaume-uni accorde le statut de
réfugié politique à litvinenko sa femme
et son fils anatolie boris berezovski
leur loue une maison à londres où il
entame une nouvelle vie
litvinenko devient détective privé et
conseiller en sécurité
il travaille aussi pour les services
secrets britanniques
après s'être installé à londres en 2000
litvinenko est resté en contact avec
beaucoup de gens en russie
ces personnes lui fournissait des
informations qu'ils remettaient aux
services secrets
il essayait aussi de vendre ses
informations des compagnies de gestion
de risque qui opérait à l'ong ces
compagnies tentaient d'aider certains
clients qui voulaient investir en russie
pour la police secrète de vladimir
poutine en russie litvinenko devient
donc le traître par excellence
il utilise même sa photo lors de leur
exercice de tir
rien de bien rassurant pour l'ex agent
russe
en 1999 une série d' énormes explosions
détruisent des tours d'habitation
entière à moscou
près de 300 personnes y trouvent la mort
la police glané séparatistes tchétchènes
mais des indices troublants laisse
croire que la police secrète du fsb a
participé ces attentats révoltants
l'opening à des officiers du fsb ont été
pris sur le fait en train de placer des
explosifs ou sous-sols d'immeubles à
logements ils prétendront plus tard que
c'était un simple entraînement
furieux alexandre litvinenko réagi à
cette nouvelle dans son livre blanc ya
rayah ce livre a prétendu que c'est le
fsb l' agence de renseignement de
poutine qui a fait exploser de façon
clandestine des tours d'habitation en
russie en 1999 et que cela justifier une
nouvelle guerre en tchétchénie et c'est
ce qui s'est passé ensuite porté par le
vent de patriotisme qui a soufflé sur le
pays à la faveur de cette guerre
vladimir poutine a été élu à la
présidence en mai 2000 avec une énorme
majorité un moment très fort pour le
nouveau régime de poutine
c'est à londres
litvinenko lui affirme que c'est un
complot machiavélique qui a permis à
poutine d'accéder au pouvoir en causant
la mort de 300 personnes
il m'a convaincu j'étais extrêmement
c'est vraiment trop incroyable que nos
propres services de sécurité faste à
klose et des immeubles
tu as un nombre aussi énorme mais les
vilains comme a dit dans le service
dégâts poursuit leur propre mère
ce sont des meurtriers pathologies comme
la douma le parlement russe a réagi en
créant une enquête officielle sur les
explosions sergey you think of un des
membres de la commission chargée de
l'enquète était assassiné en avril 2003
yuri seco shikin un autre membre et
tuées en juillet 2003 un troisième
membre auto lac six est agressée en
octobre 2003 puis meurt deux ans plus
tard dans un mystérieux accident de
voiture la journaliste et auteure russo
américaines machabée scène vivaient et
travaillaient à moscou au lendemain des
explosions toutes les personnes
impliquées de près ou de loin dans cette
enquête que ce soit des membres du
parlement des journalistes de la presse
ou de la télévision ont quitté le pays
et ont reçu des menaces
vraiment très réel pendant les cinq ou
six années qui ont suivi tous ceux qui
sont revenus ou qui sont restés en
russie tout comme litvinenko sont morts
donc l'événement lui même n'a jamais été
résolu l'enquète n'a pu apporter aucune
réponse et on en aura jamais je crois le
livre de litvinenko reste la meilleure
tentatives pour résoudre cette histoire
de façon méthodique
je trouve très convaincant est important
litvinenko avait développé une amitié
solide avec la journaliste dans quête
militante
anna politkovskaïa elle aussi a écrit
sur les explosions d'immeubles et était
extrêmement critique du régime de
poutine
elle a été empoisonné une première fois
elle a survécu mais peu de temps après
elle a été abattue dans les escaliers de
l'immeuble où elle demeurait je me
rappelle à quel point sache a été
bouleversé en apprenant la nouvelle de
sa mort fait il n'avait pas réussi à la
protéger
c'est sûr qu'il ne le pouvait pas il
avait averti des dangers qu'elle
pourrait il lui avait dit qu'elle devait
se mettre à l'abri parce que le régime
l'avait vraiment prise pour cible sur
blackberry
quand on a été tué tout est devenu très
concrets qui serait le prochain sur la
liste
conax à londres une rencontre publique
de dissidents russes a eu lieu au
frontline club juste après le meurtre de
politkovskaïa
alexandre litvinenko accuse l'a dit
mi-août in d'être derrière le meurtre de
la journaliste militant je crois que
lille vinko a été profondément affectée
par le meurtre de politkovskaïa
il n'a pas juste dénoncer son meurtre
ils étaient de grands amis et se voyait
très souvent mais il a aussi
expressément accusé vladimir poutine
d'en être le responsable
trois semaines plus tard deux présumés
assassins arrivée à moscou avec une
substance radioactive et la mission de
tuer les deux mis en cause
andreï lougovoï le principal suspect est
lui aussi un ancien agent du fsb et
litvinenko avait travaillé avec lui à
l'époque
lougovoï arrive à londres en 2005 et
proposa litvinenko une sorte de
partenariat
il voulait se lancer tous les deux en
affaires le gouverneur et des
informations de ses contacts à moscou
litvinenko les vendre et il se partagera
les profits pour faire à londres en
janvier 2006 lors du somptueux 60e
anniversaire de boris berezovski andreï
lougovoï et photographié avec quelques
personnes dont marina les devine enhco
sacha disait lougovoï travaille très dur
pour que ces affaires prennent de
l'expansion en angleterre il veut mettre
sur pied une entreprise de détectives
privés se posait pas ce moment sacha
voulait prendre sa vie en main il
devenait plus autonomes financièrement
il voulait continuer sur cette lancée
alors ils planifiaient de faire semblant
durant la dernière année de sa vie
les jean cossette implique
dans une enquête criminelle en relation
directe avec la dîmière poutine
plusieurs criminels russes avaient été
arrêtés en espagne
litvinenko devait témoigner à leur
procès pour parler de leurs liens de
longue date avec poutine qui il a aidé
les forces de l'ordre à établir hors de
tout doute les rapports personnels qu'il
y ait les criminels et des gens de
l'entourage immédiat de routine et
poutine vies humaines gros scoop route
un pontissalien remonter aux années 90
il devenait politiquement très gênante
et s'il devait y avoir un procès de la
mafia russe en espagne par exemple les
cas ce procès un officier du fsb se
présenter à la barre il deviendrait un
témoin vedette c'était le genre de
menaces qui constituait à mon avis c'est
le motif le plus plausible
litvinenko parlait à lugos veille de son
rôle dans les futurs procès en espagne
celui ci a dû partager l'information
avec moscou il semble que ce soit à ce
moment que lougovoï éco-ptz thoune ont
été recrutés pour tuer les devine qu est
que l' arme du crime a été choisi
aussitôt que litvinenko a ingéré le
polonium
il était trop tard
quand les meurtriers d'alexandre
litvinenko arrive à londres ils ignorent
qu'ils ont laissé derrière eux toute une
piste de contamination radioactive
surtout ce qu'ils ont touché la preuve
soumise à l' enquête révèle que de la
radioactivité a été détecté sur l'echez
la table et sur la théière la couleur
mauve indiquent les plus haute teneur
radioactive
ap les déviations maximale physicien
nucléaire nick priest est l'un des plus
grands experts au monde du polonium 210
le poison radioactifs utilisés par les
meurtriers de litvinenko est apte et le
thé a été contaminé on a pu le faire en
ajoutant simplement une petite quantité
de polonium dans la ville dès qu'on fait
cela la théière est contaminée
catherine si je bois le thé ma bouche et
contaminé à son tour
ici je suis ma bouche ma main sera aussi
contaminé je la pose ensuite sur la
table et elle devient contaminés à son
tour et si je m'appuie sur la banquette
je m'imprègne de radioactivité plus tard
je vais pousser la porte pour l'ouvrir
et je vais la contaminer c'est toute une
trace de contamination qu'on finit par
laisser le gouvernement russe a fait
énormément d'efforts pour chercher à
minimiser cette piste de radioactivité
qui mène tout droit à moscou le kremlin
a insinué à plusieurs reprises qu'elle
ex andres litvinenko avait sans doute
fait de la contrebande de polonium et
qu'il s'était empoisonné par mégarde
alexander negras of et un ex-conseiller
auquel il a pu s'auto contaminées en
manipulant la substance de la mauvaise
façon
par ignorance ou en ouvrant le flacon
sans précaution au parc il a pu être
assassiné par des gens vivant en
angleterre la mafia ou même les services
secrets britanniques parce qu'il parlait
trop mais non la piste ne nous mènent
pas à moscou des experts qui ont
témoigné à lenquête ont établi la
provenance du polonium
il est issu d'un réacteur nucléaire
située à sarov juste à l'est de moscou
poutine a déjà effectué des visites
officielles à la centrale de sarov où le
polonium sert de détonateur à armes
nucléaires le polonium qu'on y fabrique
est aussi vendue en occident
chaque lot de polonium produit à une
composition chimique unique qui permet
de retracer où on la produit
chaque matériau radioactif qu'on produit
dans un réacteur à sa propre signature
chimique et on sait que beaucoup de
polonium produit en russie était utilisé
en europe et en occident
donc il a été possible de comparer ce
matériau original avec le polonium
utilisé l'enquète a dévoilé que du
polonium a d'abord été transporté sur un
vol de transaero parti de moscou le 16
octobre par andreï lougovoï et dimitri
cove tone il rencontre par la suite
litvinenko dans les locaux d'une
entreprise de sécurité londonienne l'
enquête publique révèle qu'il s'agit
sans doute de la première tentative
d'assassinât elle a échoué parce que du
poison aurait été renversé la police a
retrouvé sur la nappe ni trace hautement
radioactive est aussi sur l'echez
utilisé lors de la rencontre
on ne sait pas précisément ce qui est
arrivé mais il se peut fort bien que le
polonais en était et verser dans une
carafe ou bien un verre d'eau et selon
moi il devinait mco n'a pas pu en boire
s'il avait vu ses taux ce jour là ils en
seraient morts mais ce n'est pas arrivé
les meurtriers sont rentrés au
shaftesbury hôtels et l'un d'eux il y
aurait jeté le reste du polonium dans un
lavabo le polonium a laissé des traces
de radioactivité dans le renvoi et
surtout dans le siphon où il est resté
plus longtemps le polonium reste souvent
collé aux surfaces donc si on le jette
dans le lavabo il va y rester collés il
va aussi collé sur d'autres surfaces la
céramique par exemple il colle sur tout
ce qui est métallique n en fait il
vacille amalgamer et devenir lui même
une partie de la surface métallique
marina litvinenko se souvient que son
mari a eues certain malaise le soir de
ses tentatives de meurtre il se sentait
fatigué et il n'allait pas très bien et
tout à coup il s'est mis à vomir
le lendemain il a décidé de ne pas
manger ni le surlendemain il essayait de
comprendre ce qui lui arrivait c'était
plutôt inhabituel c'est seulement quand
on a parlé aux policiers à l'hôpital la
fois suivante que je me suis rappelé de
ce soir là où sasha avaient été malades
lougovoï cov thoune sont retournés à
moscou puis lougovoï est revenu seul à
londres
une semaine plus tard le 25 octobre sans
doute pour effectuer une autre tentative
la police a détecté de la radioactivité
sur son siège d'avion
cette fois il prend une chambre à
l'hôtel park collègues
il y rencontre à quelques reprises
litvinenko après l'une de ces rencontres
lougovoï décide de retourner à sa
chambre la police découvrira plus tard
des traces de radioactivité sur une
table de chevet mais surtout dans les
toilettes
le flacon de polonium semble avoir été
jeté à la poubelle où on a détecté un
très haut niveau de radioactivité
tout comme sur le plancher et le mur
deux scientifiques se sont présentés
avec leurs détecteurs de radioactivité à
la chambre 848 que l'ouvrier avait loué
au parc les notaires en octobre 2006 et
les relevé du compteur était si inquiet
tant qu'ils sont immédiatement sortis de
la chambre à cause de son niveau de
toxicité
ça montre à quel point ce polonium était
puissant lougovoï rentrer à moscou
laissant encore une fois des traces de
radioactivité sur son siège
il revient à londres deux jours plus
tard il retrouve son complice présumé
dimitri colquhoun dès le départ
litvinenko avait trouvé comme thoune
antipathique et c'est nouveau ça chat
l'avais trouvé très désagréable plus
sociable très impoli il m'a raconté que
cost ou nuit avait dit cette phrase qu
en france et dans la vie une seule chose
ma porte et c'est l'argent voilà ce qui
compte pour moi je sache est fausse pour
sasha l'argent n'était pas une priorité
notre caractéristique
l' enquête publique a dévoilé une
incroyable histoire au moment des
préparatifs et park of town avant le
meurtre
juste avant s'envole pour londres
il semble que dimitri cov thoune se sont
rendus en allemagne où il a déjà vécu
fred a hambourg il donne rendez-vous à
un ami dans un restaurant italien où il
avait déjà travaillé
c'est la veille de l'empoisonnement il
dit à cet ami j'ai un poison extrêmement
coûteux avec lequel je dois un polonais
un traître je dois en mettre dans ce
qu'il va manger ce qu'il va boire
connaître études et cuisinier à londres
c'est stupéfiant et c'est ce qui est le
plus incroyable c'est que son ami lui
réponds oui j'en connais un il lui donne
son numéro de téléphone et le matin du
meurtre costaud on appelle le cuisinier
qui n'est pas disponible
ces choses là ne s'invente pas ça
représente une preuve de culpabilité de
lougovoï éco-ptz thoune lors de l'
enquête publique devant les images de
vidéosurveillance d'alexandre litvinenko
qui se dirige vers le millénium hôtels
et celle de lougovoï éco-ptz thoune qui
s'apprête à le tuer
marina les devine qu a ressenti une
envie d'arrêter ces images pour arrêter
le temps avait la liste je suis très
réaliste et très logique
mais en regardant ces images j'aurais
voulu changer quelque chose de lui dire
de marcher vers un autre endroit de mecs
pour que cette rencontre n'ait jamais
lieu
je sais qu'au cinéma c'est possible mais
pas dans la vie
ce qui arrive avec le polonium ce que si
on le manipule avec soin et il ne nous
tuera pas mais s'il pénètre l'organisme
parce qu'on l'a valeo s'il est injectée
en est un homme
après ce rendez vous fatidique au
millennium hôtel
alexandre litvinenko est rentré chez lui
à north london pour souper avec sa
famille y célébrer le sixième
anniversaire de leur arrivée en
angleterre à minuit il s'est mise à
vomir sans arrêt sachez dès que ça a
commencé
sacha m'a dit ça devient peut-être pas
de la nourriture c'est trop violent trop
inhabituel il disait que les symptômes
ressemblait beaucoup à ce qu'il avait
étudié sur les empoisonnements chimique
et mécanique six mois je n'arrêtais pas
lui dire non comment veux tu comptes et
administrer un poison ou quelque chose
comme ça qu'ils auraient pu le faire ça
ou que tout studio
deux jours plus tard litvinenko est
transporté à l'hôpital local puis
transféré à l'hôpital universitaire de
londres
les médecins cherchent activement les
causes de sa maladie lorsque le mot
empoisonnement et révéler les
journalistes se rassemblent devant
l'hôpital alex goude fable leur explique
l'état de litvinenko
pendant qu'il voue à la santé de son ami
se détériorer f singapore
j'avais vu quelques personnes mourir du
cancer moi et ça ressemblait vraiment
beaucoup à l'état des cancéreux en phase
terminale
sur une période de plusieurs mois a vécu
tout ça en une semaine
après douze jours litvinenko perd ses
cheveux
j'essayais de le calmer je portais des
gants de caoutchouc et je voulais
l'apaiser en posant ma main sur sa tête
ses cheveux rester collés sur mes gants
ménagers demandé ce qui se passait aux
médecins il m'a dit que c'était
peut-être un effet secondaire du
traitement médical mais je ne voulais
plus attendre j'ai demandé d'autres avis
médicaux minutes octobre au docteur et
c'est à ce moment là qu un oncologue
nous a dit que sacha était comme ces
patients qui subissent un traitement de
chimiothérapie et de radioactivité et la
dose d'irradiation qu'a reçue alexandre
litvinenko par le polonium
c'est comme si vous passiez 500 scan
d'un seul coup les médecins soupçonnent
d'abord le thallium radioactifs comme
étant la cause de l'empoisonnement mais
il écarte rapidement cette hypothèse
puisque aucune trace de radioactivité
gamma ni présente pendant ce temps la
police et des scientifiques nucléaires
recherche des indices partout s'est
rendu litvinenko
pendant que les devine qu se mourait à
londres dans sa chambre d'hôpital
les autorités britanniques ignorer la
source une à l'empoisonnement
il y avait des symptômes d'irradiation
mais sans les habituels rayonnement
gamin ce n'est que dans les dernières
heures avant sa mort que les autorités
ont identifié le polonium
pourquoi est-ce que ça a pris tout ce
temps parce que le polonium n'avez
jamais servi pour tuer ni en angleterre
ni en occident
selon les experts nucléaires les
meurtriers ont cru que le poison
passerait inaperçue il avait raison de
penser que le polonium ne serait pas
détecté après tout ce n'est que la
veille de sa mort qu'on a identifié
tout le monde aurait alors cru à une
infection ou un autre type de poison on
l'aurait alors enterré sans avoir
détecté le polonium
c'est la dernière image d'alexandre
litvinenko avant sa mort il est
extrêmement faible
le poison dans son système a criblé de
trous la poutre son visage alors je
l'ait quitté le dernier jour avant
qu'ils deviennent incapables de parler
il était très tranquille
il avait à peine parler comme j'ai dit
je m'en vais il a souri mais d'un
sourire si triste alors j'ai dit ne
t'inquiète pas ça chage revient bientôt
il m'a dit je t'aime tellement marina et
c'est si tranquille et j'ai répondu ça
fait tellement du bien de t'entendre le
dire
et ce sont les derniers mots qu'il m'a
dit alexandre litvinenko est enterré 14
jours après sa mort au cimetière ragued
à londres son cercueil et doublé de plan
pour que les porteurs ne soit pas
contaminée quant aux policiers ils ont
remonté la piste du polonium jusqu'à
moscou et à andreï lougovoï l'ancien
agent du kgb a toujours maintenu son
innocence
luke harding l'a rencontré à plusieurs
reprises
c'est comme si on lui avait enlevé sa
conscience qu'on l'avait retiré en se
servant de ciseaux il y avait un vide à
la place une froideur il était très
calculateur ce n'est pas un idiot c'est
une personne plutôt intelligente et on
lui a bien montré ce qu'il devait faire
depuis cette affaire sa carrière a fait
d'énormes bon
pendant l' enquête publique l'a dit
mi-août in à protéger lougovoï
qualifiant le travail de la police
britannique de tendancieux envers la
russie
cette enquête a été lancée suite à des
pressions de certaines personnes en
angleterre qui souhaitaient avoir
l'occasion de s'en prendre à la russie
surtout à un moment où la crise en
ukraine devenait un énorme irritant dans
les relations entre la russie et
l'occident ouest c'est une énorme
mascarade ça ne doit pas pouvoir se
faire surtout pas en grande bretagne
cette enquête était essentielle soit on
croit aux droits humains et qu'un crime
doit être sanctionné soit au contraire
on vit dans ce genre de monde ni liste
que veut poutine un monde où on croit en
rien ou tout à parti en grandes
puissances qui rivalisent pour leur zone
d'influencé
en fait on retourne au monde du 19e
siècle
depuis d'autres critiques de vladimir
poutine continue de mourir
le leader de l'opposition boris nemtsov
a été assassiné devant le kremlin en
février 2015
pendant que se tenait les enquêtes
publiques sur litvinenko à londres
art ce qui s'est passé depuis la mort de
sacha dépasse de loin notre simple
histoire ça concerne toute la russie et
toutes les personnes qui ont été tuées
et je crois que la responsabilité
revient aux gouvernements russe et à
l'homme qui a mis en oeuvre tous les
changements en russie monsieur poutine
lui même
alexandre lettonie en cabriolet on a
cité la chine hépatique sécurité sur le
toit
mon coeur est né
l' enquête britannique voulait avant
tout savoir jusqu'où vladimir poutine
pouvait être impliqué et s'il avait
lui-même ordonné ce meurtre
vladimir poutine a répété qu'il n'y
avait aucune raison de tuer alexandre
litvinenko qu'ils ne détenaient aucun
secret d'état les défenseurs de poutine
affirme que jamais ils ne se seraient
impliqués dans un assassinat l'étranger
écoutez tout d'abord aucun chef d'état
en russie ou ailleurs ne risquerait de
s'impliquer dans une telle opération
s'il le faisait il irait à l'encontre de
la nature même de son rôle comme chef
d'état c'est pourquoi je trouve toujours
ridicule d'entendre les gens accusés
poutine d'avoir ordonné un meurtre en
tant que président ça ne se passe pas
comme ça oui ça c'est déjà passé comme
ça selon de nombreux témoignages de chef
du kgb à la retraite c'était autorisé
par le politburo le sommet de l'état
soviétique par exemple l'invasion de la
crimée par les russes en 2014 poutine
disait qu'aucune troupe russe ne s'y
trouvait
puis il a admis avoir menti sans dire
aussi clairement pour dire qu'ils
avaient tous contrôlés en mode
microgestion donc ça confirme que
poutine prend de très importantes
décisions et celle ci en était sûrement
anatolie le fils d'alexandre litvinenko
n'avait que 12 ans lorsque son père est
mort il étudie l'europe de l'est à
l'université de londres
il rejette l'idée que le meurtre de son
père était commis par de simples
subalternes sans l'approbation poutine
surtout à cause des coûts de l'opération
aucun subalternes n'a les moyens
d'entreprendre une opération d'une telle
ampleur
une personne ne peut se procurer un
élément radioactif qui coûte plusieurs
millions de dollars comme le polonium
je crois aussi que personne ne peut
prendre le risque de tuer un des plus
grands critiques de l'état russe poutine
soit au courant sans avoir reçu sa
bénédiction
quand il arrive au royaume uni et qu'il
sonne l'alarmé au sujet de vladimir
poutine
litvinenko est sidéré de voir que tant
pays occidentaux accueilli
chaleureusement le président russe au
coeur même après avoir établi que la
russie ait pu autoriser le meurtre de
litvinenko
la secrétaire d'état hillary clinton a
annoncé la volonté de son pays de
remettre les compteurs à zéro pour
réinstaurer des rapports cordiaux avec
moscou de nombreux russes y ont vu de
l'aveuglément volontaire de la part de
l'ouest envers poutine on est devant un
homme qui emprisonne au dessus ses
adversaires qui détruit le système
électoral le gouvernement fédéral et
sabotent les chance d'instaurer une
justice indépendante
il aura fallu huit ans avant que les
médias occidentaux se met à évoquer de
simples tendances autoritaires mais à ce
moment là
ces tendances c'était déjà du passé il
avait consolidé un régime autoritaire de
a à z
il avait détruit le peu de démocratie
qu'on avait réussi à bâtir en russie et
à l'ouest les médias et les
gouvernements s'empêcher de voir où
faisait très peu de cas ski
fait les compteurs à zéro sont un très
bon exemple de cela c'est figurative du
nom de vladimir poutine donné l'ordre
que l'on tue mon ami qui était aussi le
mari de mon ami marina il faut qu'il en
soit tenu responsable
peu importe s'il est un dictateur un
démocrate un grand ami des états unis ou
même leurs ennemis c'est un meurtrier et
c'est ce qui compte avant tout dès le
début de l' enquête le juge robert wayne
avait déjà insisté sur la vraisemblance
de l'implication du gouvernement russe
comme commanditaire du meurtre il y a
cinq ans une fuite avait révélé que
diplomate américain de haut rang avait
confié à des vis-à-vis européen que
l'assassinât de litvinenko aurait été
impossible sans que poutine en soit visé
est ni donne son aval
dans son rapport final le juge owen a
conclu que poutine a probablement
approuvé l'assassinât il s'ensuit un
défi majeur pour le gouvernement
britannique et l'occident comment
interagir avec un leader mondial qui
pour presque tous en commandite et